hello welcome to cs224n
today we'll be talking about
pre-training uh which is another
exciting topic on the road to Modern
natural language processing
um okay
how is everyone doing thumbs up some
side thumbs down
wow no response bias there all you know
all thumbs up oh sorry nice I like that
Honesty that's good well
um okay so we're now uh what is this
week five
yes it's week five and
um we have a couple so this lecture
um the Transformers lecture and then to
a lesser extent Thursday's lecture on
natural language Generation
Um will be sort of the sum of lectures
for the assignments you have to do right
so assignment five is coming out on uh
Thursday
um and uh the the topics covered in this
lecture and the you know self-attention
Transformers and again a little bit of
natural language generation will be
tested in assignment five and then the
rest of the course will go through some
really fascinating topics and sort of
modern uh natural language processing
that should be useful for your final
projects and future jobs and interviews
and intellectual curiosity and
um but uh you know I think that this
today's lecture is significantly less
um uh technical in detail than last
Thursdays on self-attention and
Transformers but should give you an idea
of this sort of uh world of pre-training
and sort of how it helps Define
uh natural language processing today
um so a reminder about assignment five
your project proposals also are due on
Tuesday next Tuesday
um please do get those in try to get
them in on time so that we can give you
prompt feedback about your project
proposals
um and yeah so let's let's jump into it
okay so uh what we're going to start
with today is
um a bit of a technical detail on uh
word structure and sort of how we model
the input sequence of words that we get
so um in when we were teaching word to
VEC and uh sort of all the methods that
we've talked about so far we assumed a
finite vocabulary right so we had a
vocabulary V that you define via
whatever you've looked at some data
you've decided what the words are in in
that data and so you know
um you have some words uh like hat and
learn and uh you know you have this
embedding it's in red because you've
learned it properly actually let's
replace hat and learn with pizza and
tasty those are better
um and uh and so that's all well and
good you see these words uh in your
model and
you have an embedding that's been
learned on your data uh to sort of know
what to do when you see those words but
when you see some sort of variations
maybe you see like tasty and maybe a
typo like learn
um or or maybe novel items where it's
like a word that you know you as a human
can understand as sort of this
combination this is called derivational
morphology uh of like this word
Transformer that you know and if I which
means you know take this noun and give
me back you know a verb that means to
make more like that noun to Transformer
if I NLP might mean to you know make NLP
more like using Transformers and such
um and for each of these right this
maybe didn't show up in your in your
training Corpus and language is uh
always doing this right people are
always coming up with new words and
there's new domains and there's the you
know young people are always making new
words it's great and so it's a problem
for your model though right because
you've defined this finite vocabulary
and there's sort of no mapping
in that vocabulary for each of these
things even though their meanings should
be relatively well defined based on the
data you've seen so far it's just that
the sort of string of characters that
Define them
aren't quite what you've seen
and so what do you do well maybe you map
them to this sort of universal unknown
tokens this is Unk uh right so it's like
oh I see something I don't know what
I've never seen it before I'm going to
say it's always represented by the same
token ankh
um and so that's been done in the past
uh and that's sort of bad right because
it's totally in like losing tons of
information
um but you know you need to map it to
something
uh and so that this is like a clear
problem especially I mean in English
it's a problem in many of the world's
languages it's a substantially larger
problem right so
um you know English has relatively
simple word structure there's a couple
of conjugations for each verb like you
know eat eats eaten ate
um but in a language uh with much more
complex morphology or word structure
um you'll have a considerably more
complex uh sort of set of things that
you could see in the world so here is a
a conjugation table for a Swahili verb
and it has over 300 conjugations
and if I Define the vocabulary to be
every unique string of characters uh
maps to its own word then every one of
the 300 conjugations would get an
independent Vector under my model which
makes no sense because the 300
conjugations obviously have a lot in
common
and differ by sort of meaningful uh
extents so you don't want to do this I'd
have to have a huge vocabulary uh if I
wanted all conjugations to show up and
that's that's a mistake for efficiency
reasons and for learning reasons
any questions so far
cool
okay
um and so what we end up uh doing
um is we'll look at subword sub word
structure sub word modeling so what
we're going to do is we're going to say
I'm not going to even try to Define what
the set of all words is I'm going to
Define my vocabulary to include parts of
words
there
where am I oh
uh right so um
so I'm going to split words into
sequences of known sub words and so
there's a simple sort of algorithm for
this where you start with all characters
right so if I only had a vocabulary of
all characters and maybe like an end of
word symbol
um I ha for a finite data set then I
could no matter what word I saw in the
future as long as I had seen all
possible characters I could take the
word and say I don't know what this word
is I'm going to split it into like all
of its individual characters so you
won't have this UNC problem you can sort
of represent any word and then you're
going to find common adjacent characters
and say okay A and B co-occur next to
each other quite a bit so I'm going to
add a new word to my vocabulary
now it's all characters plus this new
word a b which is a sub word
and likewise I'm going so now I'm going
to replace the character pair with the
new sub word and repeat until you add a
lot a lot a lot of vocabulary items
through this process of what things tend
to co-occur next to each other and so
what you'll end up with is a vocabulary
a very commonly a co-occurring sort of
substrings by which you can build up
words
and this was originally developed for
machine translation but then has been
used considerably in pretty much all
modern language models so now we have a
hat and learn hat and learn so in our
sub word vocabulary hat and learn showed
up enough that they're their own
individual words so that's sort of good
right so simple common words show up as
a word in your vocabulary just like
you'd like them to but now tasty maybe
gets split into TAA and then maybe you
know in some cases this Hash Hash means
like don't add a space next right so TAA
and then AAA and then s-t-y right so
I've actually taken one sort of thing
that seems like a word and in my
vocabulary it's now split into three sub
word tokens
so when I pass this to my Transformer or
to my recurrent neural network right the
recurrent neural network would take TAA
as a as just a single element do the RNN
update and then take AAA do the RNA and
update and then sty so it could learn
to process constructions like this and
maybe I can even add more aaas in the
middle right and have it do something
similar
instead of just seeing the entire word
tasty
and not knowing what it means
is that that's feedback yeah
uh
how loud is that feedback
we good
okay I think we're fixed great
um
and so same with Transformer if I maybe
Transformer as its own word and then if
I and so you can see that you have sort
of three learned embeddings instead of
one sort of useless unkem betting this
is just wildly useful and is used pretty
much everywhere variants of this
algorithm are used pretty much
everywhere in uh like modern NLP
questions yes
if we have three embeddings for tasty do
we just add them together
so the question is if we have three
embeddings for tasty do we just add them
together uh if we want to represent so
when we're actually processing the
sequence I'd see something like I
learned about the TAA AAA sty so it'd
actually be totally separate tokens but
if I wanted to then say what's my
representation of this thing
uh depends on what you want to do
sometimes you average you average the
contextual representations of the three
or look at the last one maybe it at that
point it's unclear what to do but
everything sort of works okay
click how do you what how do you know
where to split yeah so um you know where
to split based on the algorithm that I
uh specified earlier for learning the
vocabulary so you've learned this
vocabulary by just combining commonly
co-occurring adjacent strings of letters
right so like a b co-occurred a lot so
now I've got a new word that's a b
um and then when I'm actually walking
through and tokenizing I try to split as
little as possible so I split words into
the maximal uh sort of sub word that
takes up the most characters they're
algorithms for this uh yeah so like I'm
like okay if I want to split this up you
know like there's many ways I could
split it up and you try to find some
approximate like what the best way to
split it into the fewest words is yeah
do I ask the question is do people make
use punctuation in the character set how
do people do it yes absolutely so you
know sort of from this point on so uh
just assume that what text is given to
these models is as unprocessed as
possible you take it you try to make it
sort of clean looking text where you've
removed you know HTML tags maybe if it's
from the Internet or or whatever
um but then beyond that you process it
as little as possible so that it
reflects as well as possible what people
might actually be using this for
um so maybe earlier in the course when
we were looking at word to VEC maybe we
had what might have thought about oh we
don't want word to vectors of
punctuation or something like that
um now everything is just as close as
possible to what the text you'd get with
people trying to use your system would
be so yes uh in practice punctuation and
like dot dot dot might be its own word
you know and and maybe a sequence of
like hyphens because people make big
bars across you know tables yeah
foreign
[Music]
could be multiple embeddings versus a
single embedding like this is the
like system tree those any differently
uh the question is does the system treat
any differently words that are like
really themselves the whole word versus
words that are sort of pieces you know
the system has no idea they're all just
indices into your embedding vocabulary
Matrix
um so they're all treated equally
about really long ones that are I guess
relatively common because if you're
building up from the same character all
the way up what happens then yeah the
question is what happens to very long
words uh if you're building up some sort
of character Pairs and portions of
characters uh you know in practice the
statistics speak really well for
themselves so if a long word is very
common it will end up in the vocabulary
and uh if it's not very common it won't
um there are algorithms that aren't this
that do slightly better in various ways
um but the intuition that you sort of
figure out what the common co-occurring
substrings are sort of independent of
length almost is is the right intuition
to have and so yeah you can actually
just look at the Learned vocabularies of
a lot of these models and uh you see
some long words
uh just because they if they showed up a
lot
I'm curious how does it weigh the uh
like the frequency so let's say there's
like if ify or at the in your next slide
it was like goodbye
um at the very last one so if could be
really common so how did the weight like
the frequency of a sub word versus the
length of it like it tries to spread it
up into the smallest number but what if
it split it up into three but one of
them was super common
yeah so the question is uh you know if
Transformer is a sub word in my
vocabulary and if it's a sub word and Y
is a sub word and if I as a three letter
Tuple is also a sub word how does it
choose to like take the you know if I
maybe it's not very common uh as opposed
to splitting it into more subwords
um it's just a choice we choose to try
to take the smallest number of sub words
because that tends to be uh more of the
bottleneck as opposed to the having a
bunch of very common very short sub
words uh trans you know sequence length
is a big problem in Transformers and
this seems to be sort of what works
although trying to split things into
multiple options of a sequence and
running the Transformer on all of them
is the thing that people have done to
see which one will work better
but yeah having fewer bigger sub words
tends to be the best sort of idea I'm
going to start moving on though uh feel
free to ask me more questions about this
afterward
okay so um
so let's talk about pre-training from
the context of the course so far uh so
we at the very beginning of the course
we gave you this quote which was you
know you shall know a word by the
company it keeps this was the sort of
thesis of the distributional hypothesis
right that the meaning of the word is
defined by or at least reflected by what
words it tends to co-occur around and we
implemented this via word to VEC
uh the same person who made that quote
had a separate quote actually earlier uh
that continues this sort of notion of
meaning as defined by context which has
something along the lines of well you
know since the word shows up in context
when we actually use it when we speak to
each other the meaning of the word
should be defined in the context that it
actually shows up in and so uh you know
the complete meaning of a word is always
contextual and no study of meaning apart
from a complete context can be taken
seriously so right the big difference
here is like at word tovec training time
if I have uh the word uh record
r-e-c-o-r-d
when I'm training word to VEC I get one
vector or two but you know one one
vector meaning uh record the string
um
and uh it has to learn by what context
it shows up in that sometimes you know
it can mean I record I.E the verb or
record I.E the noun right but I only
have one vector to represent it and so
when I use the word embedding of record
uh it sort of has this mixture meaning
of both of its sort of Senses right it
doesn't get to specialize and say oh
this part means record and this part
means record
and so where to back is going to just
sort of fail
um and and so I can build better
representations of language through
these contextual uh representations that
are going to take things like recurrent
neural networks or Transformers that we
used before to build up sort of
contextual meaning
uh so so what we had before were
pre-trained word embeddings and then we
had sort of a a big box on top of it
like a Transformer or an lstm that was
not pre-trained right so so you learn
via context your word embeddings here
and then uh you have a task like
sentiment analysis or machine
translation or or parsing or whatever
and you initialize all the parameters of
this randomly and then you train uh to
predict your label
and the the big difference uh in you
know today's work is that we're going to
try to pre-train all the parameters so I
have my big Transformer and instead of
just you know pre-training my word
embeddings with word to VEC I'm going to
train all of the parameters of the
network
uh trying to teach it you know much more
about language uh that I could use in my
in my Downstream tasks so now I'm sort
of the the labeled data that I have for
say machine translation might need to be
smaller I might not need as much of it
because I've already trained much more
of the network than I otherwise would
have if I had just gotten sort of word
to back embeddings
okay so so here right I've pre-trained
this entire sort of structure the word
embeddings the Transformer on top
everything's been trained via methods
that we'll talk about today and so what
does this give you I mean it gives you
very strong representations of language
so the meaning of record and record will
be different in the sort of contextual
representations that know what where in
the sequence it is and what words are
co-occurring with it in the specific
input then word to back which only has
one representation for record
independent of where it shows up it'll
also be used as strong parameter
initializations for NLP models so in all
of your homework so far you've worked
with uh you know building out a natural
language processing system sort of from
scratch right like how do I initialize
this weight Matrix and we always say oh
you know small normally distributed
noise like little values you know uh
close to zero and here we're going to
say well just like we were going to you
know use the word to VEC embeddings and
those sort of encoded structure I'm
going to start maybe my machine
translation system from a parameter
initialization that's given to me via
pre-training
and then also it's going to give us
probability distributions over language
that we can use to to generate and
otherwise and we'll talk about this
okay so whole models are going to be
pre-trained so um all of pre-training is
effectively going to be centered around
this idea of reconstructing the input so
you have an input it's a sequence of
text that some human has generated and
the sort of hypothesis is that by
masking out part of it
and tasking a neural network with
reconstructing the original input
that neural network has to learn a lot
about language about the world in order
to do a good job of reconstructing the
input right so this is now a supervised
learning problem just like you know
machine translation right I've taken
this sentence that just existed Stanford
University is located in say Palo Alto
California or Stanford California I
guess
um
and I have by removing this you know
part of the sentence uh made a label for
myself right the input is this sort of
broken uh mask sentence and the label is
Stanford or Palo Alto
so if I give this example to a network
and ask it to predict the center thing
as it's doing its gradient step on this
input it's going to encode information
about the co-occurrence between this
context Stanford University is located
in and Palo Alto so by tasking it with
this it might learn say where Stanford
is
what else might it learn well it can
learn things about maybe syntax so I put
blank Fork down on the table
um here there's only a certain set of
words that could go here I put the fork
down on the table I put a fork down to
the table these are syntactic
constraints
right so the context shows me sort of
What kinds of words can appear in what
kinds of contexts
the woman walked across the street
checking for traffic over blank shoulder
any ideas on what could go here
right so um this sort of this sort of co
uh co-reference between this entity who
is being discussed in the world this
woman and her shoulder now when I
discuss you know this is sort of
linguistic concept the word her here is
a co-referrent to woman right it's
referring to the same entity in the
discourse and so the network might be
able to learn things about you know like
kind of what entities are doing what
where
uh it can learn things about sort of
semantics so if I have I went to the
ocean to see the fish Turtle seals and
blank then the word that's in the blank
should be sort of a member of the class
that I'm thinking of as a person writing
this sentence of stuff that I see when I
go to the ocean and see these other
things as well right so in order to do
this prediction task maybe I learned
about you know the semantics of of uh
aquatic creatures
okay so what else could I learn I've got
overall the value I got from the two
hours watching it was the sum total of
the popcorn and drink the the movie was
blank what kind of task could I be
learning from doing this sort of
prediction problem
sentiment exactly so this is just a
naturalistic sort of text that I
naturally wrote uh myself
um but by saying oh the movie was bad
I'm learning about sort of the latent
sentiment of the person who wrote This
what they were feeling about the movie
at the time
so maybe if I see a new review later on
I can just paste in the review say the
movie was blank
and if the model generates bad or good
that could be implicitly solving the
task of sentiment analysis
so here's another one Ira went to the
kitchen to make some tea standing next
to Ira Zuko pondered his Destiny Zuko
left the blank
okay so in this scenario we've got a
world implicitly that's been designed by
the person who is creating this text
right I've got physical locations in the
discourse like the kitchen uh and I've
got Zuko uh we've got iros in the
kitchen Zuko's next to iro
so Zuko must be in the kitchen
so what could Zuko leave but the kitchen
right and so in terms of you know latent
Notions of embodiment and physical
location the way that people talk about
people you know being next to something
and then leaving something could tell
you uh stuff about sort of yeah a little
bit about how the world works even
so here's the secret sequence I was
thinking about the sequence that goes
one one two three five eight thirteen
twenty one uh blank
and
um you know this is a pretty tough one
right
this is the Fibonacci sequence right
create a model by looking at the a bunch
of numbers from the Fibonacci sequence
learn to in general predict the next one
a question you should be thinking about
throughout the lecture
okay any questions on these sort of
examples of what you might learn from
predicting the context
okay okay cool
um so uh
you know a very simple way to think
about pre-training is pre-training is
language modeling so we saw language
modeling earlier in the course and now
we're just going to say instead of using
my language model just to provide
probabilities over the next word I am
going to train it on that task right I'm
going to actually model the distribution
P Theta of the word t given all the
words previous
and there's a ton of data for this right
there's you know there's just an amazing
amount of data for this in a lot of
languages especially English there's
very little data for this in actually
most of the world's languages which is a
separate problem
um but you can free train just through
language modeling right so I'm going to
sort of do the teacher forcing thing so
I have IRL I predict goes I have goes I
predict two and I'm going to train my
sort of lstm or my Transformer to do
this task and then I'm just going to
keep all the weights
okay I'm going to save all the network
parameters
um and then once I have these parameters
right instead of generating from my
language model I'm just going to use
them as an initialization for my
parameters so I have this pre-training
fine tuning Paradigm two steps most of
you I think in your well maybe not this
year let's say a large portion of you
this year in your final projects will be
doing the pre-training fine-tuning sort
of Paradigm where someone has done the
pre-training for you right so you have a
ton of text you learn very general
things about the distribution of words
and sort of the latent things that that
tells you about the world and about
language and then in step two you've got
some tasks maybe sentiment analysis and
you have maybe not very many labels you
have a little bit of labeled data
and you adapt the pre-trained model to
the task that you care about by further
doing gradient steps on this task so you
give it the movie was you predict happy
or sad and then
um
you sort of Continue to update the
parameters based on the initialization
from the pre-training
and this just works exceptionally well I
mean unbelievably well compared to
training from scratch
intuitively because you've taken a lot
of the burden of learning about language
learning about the world off of the data
that you've labeled for sentiment
analysis and you're sort of giving that
task of learning all this sort of very
general stuff to the much more General
task of language modeling yes
but we didn't have much data in other
languages what do you mean by that was
it just text in that language yeah
labeled in some way so the question is
uh you know you said we have a lot of
data in English but not in other
languages
um what do you mean by data that we
don't have a lot of in other languages
is it just text it's literally just
text no annotations because you don't
need annotations to do language model
pre-training right the existence of that
sequence of words that someone has
written
provides you with all these pairs of
input and output input iro output goes
input iro goes output two those are all
labels sort of that you've constructed
from the input just existing but you
know in most languages even on the
entire internet I mean there's about 7
000 ish languages on Earth and most of
them don't have the sort of you know
uh billions of words that you might want
to to train these systems on uh yeah
entire thing are you still only like one
vector representation per word
the question is if you're pre-training
the entire thing do you still learn one
vector representation per word you learn
one vector representation that is the
non-contextual input vector
right so you have your vocabulary Matrix
you've got your embedding Matrix that is
vocabulary size by model dimensionality
and so yeah iro has one vector goes has
one vector
but then the Transformer that you're
learning on top of it takes in the
sequence so far and sort of gives a
vector to each of them that's dependent
on the context in that case but still at
the input you only have one embedding
per word
yeah so what's sort of like metric would
you use to like evaluate
it's supposed to be like General right
so but things like application specific
metrics which one do you use yeah so the
question is what metric do you use to
evaluate pre-trained models since it's
supposed to be so General
um but there are lots of sort of very
specific evaluations you could use
um it will get into a lot of that in the
rest of the lecture uh while you're
training it you can use Simple metrics
that sort of correlate with what you
want but aren't actually what you want
just like the probability quality right
so you can evaluate the perplexity of
your language model just like you would
have when you cared about language
modeling and it turns out to be the case
that better perplexity correlates with
all the stuff that's much harder to
evaluate like lots and lots of different
tasks but also the natural language
processing Community has built very
large sort of Benchmark Suites of
varying tasks to try to get at sort of a
notion of generality although that's
very very difficult it's sort of
ill-defined even and so when you develop
new pre-training methods what you often
do is you try to pick a whole bunch of
evaluations and show that you do better
on all of them you know and and that's
your argument for generality
okay
um so so why should this sort of
pre-training fine-tuning two-part
Paradigm help uh you know this is still
an open area of research but the
intuitions are all you're going to take
from this course so right so
pre-training provides some sort of
starting uh parameters L Theta so this
is like all the parameters in your
network right from trying to do this
minimum over all possible settings of
your parameters of the pre-training loss
and then the fine-tuning process takes
uh you know your data for fine tuning
you've got some labels and it tries to
approximate the minimum through gradient
Descent of the loss of the fine-tuning
task of theta but you start at Theta hat
right so you start gradient descent at
Theta hat which your pre-training
process gave you
and then you know
if you could actually solve this Min and
wanted to it sort of feels like the
starting point shouldn't matter
but it really really really does it
really does
um uh so that's and we'll talk a bit
more about this later but
um the process of gradient descent you
know maybe it sticks relatively close to
the Theta hat during fine tuning right
so
um you know you start at Theta hat and
then you sort of walk downhill with
gradient descent until you hit sort of a
valley and that Valley ends up being
really good because it's close to the
pre-training parameters which were
really good for a lot of things this is
a cool place where sort of practice and
Theory are sort of like meeting where
like optimization people want to
understand why this is so useful NLP
people sort of just want to build better
systems
um
so uh
yeah maybe the stuff around Theta hat
tends to generalize well if you want to
work on this kind of thing you should
talk about it yeah
the classic waiting to send sticks
relatively close but what if we were to
use a different Optimizer how would that
change their results the question is uh
if stochastic gradient descent sticks
relatively close what if we use a
different Optimizer I mean if we use
sort of any common variant of gradient
descent like any first order method like
atom which we use in this course or add
a grad or they all have this very very
similar properties
um other types of optimization we just
tend to not use so who knows ah yeah
yeah fine tuning works better than just
fine tuning but making article like
adding more layers more data yeah uh the
question is why does the pre-trained
fine-tuned Paradigm work better than
just making the model more powerful
adding more layers adding more data to
just the fine tuning
um
that's a you know the simple answer is
that you have orders of magnitude more
data that's unlabeled
that's just text
that you found
then you do you know carefully labeled
data and the tasks that you care about
right because that's expensive to get it
has to be examples of your movie reviews
or whatever that you've had someone
label carefully
um so you have you know something like
on the internet
uh at least five trillion maybe 10
trillion words of this and you have
maybe a million words of your label data
or whatever over here so it's just like
the it's just the scale is way off
um but there's also an intuition that
like learning to do a very very simple
thing like sentiment analysis
um is not going to get you a very
general
generally able agent in a wide range of
settings compared to language modeling
so like it's hard to get how to put it
even if you have a lot of labeled data
of movie reviews of the kind that people
are writing today
maybe tomorrow they start writing
slightly different kinds of movie
reviews and your system doesn't perform
as well whereas if you pre-trained on a
really diverse set of text from a wide
range of sources in people it might be
more adaptable to seeing stuff that
doesn't quite look like the training
data you showed it even if you showed it
a ton of training data so one of the
sort of big takeaways of pre-training is
that you get this huge amount of sort of
variety of text uh on the internet you
have to be very careful I mean you yeah
you should be very careful about what
kind of text you're showing it and what
kind of text you're not because the
internet is full of you know
um awful text as well
um but some of that generality just
comes from how hard this problem is and
how much data you can show it
so much data how do you then train it so
that it considers the stuff that you're
fine-tuning it with as like more
important more sale into a passive Trend
if you rather than just one in a billion
articles
yeah it's a good question so the
question is uh given that the amount of
data on the pre-training side is orders
of magnitude more than the amount of
data on the fine tuning side how do you
sort of get across to the model that
okay actually the fine tuning task is
like what I care about so like focus on
that
um it's it's about the fact that I did
this first the pre-training first and
then I do the fine tuning second right
so I've done I've gotten my parameter
initialization from this I've set it
somewhere and then I fine tune I move to
where the parameters are doing well for
this task afterward and so well it might
just forget a lot about how to do this
because now I'm just asking it to do
this at this point
uh I should move on I think
um but we're going to keep talking about
this in in much more detail with more
concrete uh elements so
um
okay so uh let's talk about model
pre-training oh wait
that did not Advance the slides
nice okay let's talk about model
pre-training three ways uh in our
Transformers lecture uh Tuesday we
talked about encoders encoder decoders
and decoders and we'll we'll do decoders
last because
um actually many of the largest models
uh that are being used today Are all uh
decoders and so we'll have a bit more to
say about them
um right so let's recall these three so
encoders get bi-directional context you
have a single sequence and you're able
to see the whole thing kind of like an
encoder in machine translation
encoder decoders have one uh portion of
the network that gets bi-directional
context so that's like the source
sentence of my machine translation
system and then they're sort of paired
with a decoder that gets unidirectional
context so that I have this sort of uh
informational masking where I can't see
the future so that I can do things like
language modeling I can generate the
next token of my translation whatever so
you could think of it as you know I've
got my source sentence here and my
partial translation here and I'm sort of
decoding out the translation
and then decoders only are things like
language models we've seen a lot of this
so far and there's pre-training for all
three sort of large classes of models
and how you pre-train them and then how
you use them depends on the properties
and the productivities of the specific
architecture so let's let's look at
encoders first
um so we've looked at language modeling
quite a bit but we can't do language
modeling with an encoder because they
get bi-directional context right so if
I'm down here uh at I and I want to
present I want to predict the next word
it's a trivial task at the at this level
here to predict the next word because in
the middle I was able to look at the
next word
and so I should just know there's
nothing hard about learning to predict
the next word here because I could just
look at it see what it is and then you
know copy it over so when I'm training
an encoder in something uh for for
pre-training I have to be a little bit
more clever
in practice what I do is something like
this uh I take the input and I modify it
somewhat I mask out words sort of like I
did in the examples I gave at the
beginning of class so I blank to the
blank
right and then I have the network
predict uh with this whole you know I
haven't built contextual representations
so now this Vector representation of the
blank sees the entire context around it
here and then I predict the word went
and then here the word store
any questions
okay and you can see how this is doing
something quite a bit like language
modeling but with you know
bi-directional context I've removed the
Network's information about the words
that go in the blanks and I'm training
it to reconstruct that so I only have
lost terms right I only ask it to
actually do the prediction compute the
loss back propagate the gradients for
the words that I've masked out
and you can think of this as you know
instead of learning probability of X
where X is like a sentence or a document
this is learning the probability of X
the real document given X tilde which is
this sort of corrupted document
with some of the information missing
missing
okay and so maybe we get the sequence of
vectors here one per word which is the
output of my encoder in blue and then
I'd say that for the words that I want
to predict y i i draw them this is the
Sim means the probability is uh
proportional to uh you know my embedding
Matrix times
um my representation of it so it's a
linear transformation of that last thing
here so this a plus b is this red
portion here and then do the prediction
and I train the entire network to do
this yes
so
far do we just
do it as we are is there something you
can do it the question is do we just
choose words randomly to mask out or is
there a scheme mostly randomly we'll
talk about a slightly smarter scheme in
a couple of slides but yeah just mostly
randomly
uh yeah
what was that last part on the bottom
um exit the maps version of like if it's
the first
or the very last sentence uh yeah so so
I'm saying that I'm defining X tilde to
be this input part where I've got the
masked version of the sentence with
these sort of words missing and then I'm
defining a probability distribution
that's the probability of a sequence
conditioned on the input being the sort
of corrupted sequence the masked
sequence
okay
um so uh this brings us to a very very
popular and uh sort of NLP model that
you need to know about it's called Bert
and it was the first one to popularize
this masked language modeling objective
um and they released the weights of this
pre-trained Transformer that they
pre-trained via something that looks a
lot like Mass language modeling and so
these you can download you can use them
via a code that's released by the
company hugging face that we have you
know continue to bring up many of you
will use a model like Birch in your
final project because it's such a useful
builder of representations of language
and context so let's talk a little bit
about the details of mass language
modeling in Bert
first we'd take 15 of the sub word
tokens so remember all of our inputs now
are subword tokens I'm making I've made
them all look like words but just like
we saw at the very beginning of class
each of these tokens could just be some
portion some sub word and I'm going to
do a couple of things with it sometimes
I am going to just mask out the word
and then you know predict the true word
sometimes I'm going to replace the word
with some random sample of another word
from my distribution from my vocabulary
and predict the real word that was
supposed to go there and sometimes I'm
going to not change the word at all and
still predict it the intuition of this
is the following
um if I just had to build good
representations
of uh in the sort of middle of this
network for words that are masked out
then when I actually use the model at
test time on some real you know review
to do sentiment analysis on well there
are never going to be any tokens like
this so maybe the model won't do a very
good job because it's like oh you know I
have no job to do here because I only
need to deal with the mask tokens
by giving it sequences of words where
sometimes it's the real word that needs
to be predicted sometimes you have to
detect if the word is wrong the idea is
that now when I give it a sentence uh
that doesn't have any masks it actually
sort of does a good job of representing
all the words in context because it has
this chance that it could be asked to
predict anything at any time
okay so uh the folks at uh at Google who
were defining this had a separate
additional task that is sort of
interesting to think about
so this was their their Bert model from
their paper they had their position
embeddings just like we saw from our
Transformers lecture token embeddings
just like we saw from the Transformers
lecture but then also they had this
thing called a segment embedding where
they had two possible segments segment a
and segment B
and uh they had this additional task
where they would get a big chunk of text
for Segment a and a big chunk of text
for Segment B and then they would ask
the model is segment b a real
continuation of segment a well so the
text that actually came next or did I
just pick this big segment randomly from
somewhere else
and the idea is that this should teach
the network something some notion of
sort of long distance coherence right
about sort of the connection between a
bunch of text over here and a bunch of
text over there
turns out it's not really necessary but
it's an interesting idea
and sort of similar things have
continued to have some sort of influence
since then but again you should get this
intuition that we're trying to come up
with hard problems for the network to
solve such that by solving them it has
to learn a lot about language
and we're defining those problems by
making simple Transformations or
removing information from text that just
happen to occur
questions
yeah the plus signs do we concatenate
the vector so do we do an element-wise
Edition uh the question is for these
plus signs do we concatenate the vectors
or do element wise Edition we do element
wise Edition uh you could have
concatenated them
however the one of the big sort of
conventions of all these networks is
that you always have exactly the same
number of Dimensions everywhere at every
layer of the network it just makes
everything very simple so just saying
everything's the same Dimension and then
uh doing addition just ends up being
simpler
yeah
the next sentence prediction not
necessarily
yeah why was the next sentence
prediction not necessary I mean it one
thing that it does that's a negative is
that now
um
the sort of content the effective
context length for a lot of your
examples is halved
so one of the things that's useful about
pre-training seemingly is that you get
to build representations of very long
sequences of text so this is very short
but in practice segment a was going to
be something like 250 words and segment
B was going to be 250 words and in the
paper that sort of let us know that this
wasn't necessary they always had a long
segment of 500 Words
and it seemed to be useful to always
have this very long context because
longer contexts help give you more
information about the role that each
word is playing in that specific context
right if I see one word it's hard to
know if it's just the record it's hard
to know what it's supposed to mean but
if I see a thousand words around it it's
much clearer what its role is in that
context is so yeah it cuts the effective
context size as one answer
um
what another thing is that this is
actually much more difficult this is a
much more recent paper uh that I don't
have in the slides but it's been shown
since then that these models are really
really bad at the next sentence
prediction task so it could be that
maybe it just like was too hard at the
time
uh and so it just like wasn't useful
because the model was failing to do it
at all
so I give the link for that paper later
why we need to do a next sentence
prediction what about just masking and
predicting I missed that jump so
yeah so the question is why do we need
to do next sentence prediction why not
just do the masking we saw before that's
the thing you seem to not need to do
next to this prediction but you know as
sort of like his history of the research
it was thought that this was useful
and the idea is that it required you to
develop this sort of pairwise like do
these two segments of text interact how
do they interact are they related the
sort of longer distance notion and many
NLP tasks are defined on pairs of things
and they thought that might be useful
and so they published it with this and
then someone else came through published
a new model that didn't do that and it
and it sort of did better
so you know this is just yeah so yeah uh
there are intuitions as to why it could
work it just didn't
it was doing both it was doing both this
next sentence so Bert was doing both
this next sentence prediction uh
evaluate uh training as well as this
masking training uh all at the same time
and so you had to have a separate
predictor head on top of bird a separate
predictor sort of classification thing
and you know so one detail there is that
there's this special word at the
beginning of Bert in every sequence
that's CLS and you know you can define a
predictor on top of that sort of fake
word embedding that was going to say is
the next sentence real or fake or not
yeah
okay I'm gonna move on
um and so this gets that sort of the
question that we had earlier about how
do you evaluate these things
um there's a lot of different NLP tasks
out there gosh and uh you know when
people were defining these papers they
would look at a ton of different
evaluations that had been sort of
compiled as a set of things that are
still hard for today's systems so are
you detecting paraphrases between
questions or two quora questions
actually the same question that turns
out to be hard
um you know uh can you do sentiment
analysis on this hard data set can you
tell if sentences are linguistically
acceptable are they grammatical or not
um are two sequences similar
semantically do they mean sort of
vaguely the similar thing
um and we'll talk a bit about natural
language inference later but that's the
task of defining sort of if I say you
know I saw the dog that does not
necessarily mean I saw the little dog
but saying I saw the little dog does
mean I saw the dog so that's sort of
this natural language inference task and
you know the Striking the difference
between sort of pre-pre-training days
where you had this sort of this row here
before you had substantial amounts of
pre-training and Bert was just like the
field was taken aback in a way that's
hard to describe
you know very carefully crafted
architectures for each individual task
where everyone was designing their own
neural network and doing things that
they thought were sort of clever as to
how to define all the connections and
the weights and whatever to do their
tasks independently so everyone was
doing a different thing for each one of
these tasks roughly
all of that was blown out of the water
by just build a big Transformer and just
teach it to predict the missing words a
whole bunch and then fine tune it on
each of these tasks
so this was this was just a sea change
in the field people were I mean amazed
it's a little bit less flashy than chat
GPT I'll admit but it's really part of
the story that gets us to it you know
um okay
questions
so like uh to get stuff out of the like
the during the encode their pre-training
stage encoder usually outputs like uh
some sort of hidden values how do we
correlate those the words that we are
trying to test against
so the question is you know the the
encoder output is a bunch of you know
hidden values
um how do we actually correlate those
values to stuff that we want to predict
I'm going to go on to the next slide
here to bring up this this example here
right so the encoder gives us for each
input word token a vector of that token
that represents the token in context and
the question is you know how do we get
these representations and and turn them
into uh sort of answers for the tasks
that we care about and
um
the answer comes back to
do
[Music]
something like this uh
something like this
Maybe
wow sure
um so when we were doing a pre-training
right we had the Transformer that was
giving us our representations and we had
this little last layer here this little
um sort of affine uh transformation that
moved us from the encoder's hidden State
size to the vocabulary to do our
prediction and we just removed this last
prediction layer here and let's say we
want to do something that is uh
classifying the sentiment of the
sentence we just pick arbitrarily maybe
the last word in the sentence and we
stick a linear classifier on top and map
it to positive or negative and then fine
tune the whole thing
okay so so yeah the Bert model uh had uh
two different models one was 110 million
parameters one was 340 million keep that
sort of in the back of your head sort of
percolating as we talk about models with
with many many more parameters later on
it was trained on
um uh
800 million words plus that is
definitely wrong maybe two point maybe
25 million words but on the order of
less than a billion words of text quite
a bit still
um and it was trained on what was
considered at the time to be a whole lot
of compute just you know it was Google
doing this and they released it and we
were like oh who has that kind of
compute but Google although nowadays
it's not considered to be very much
um but fine-tuning is practical and
common on a single GPU so you could take
the burp model that they'd spend a lot
of time training and fine-tune it
yourself on your task uh on even sort of
a very a very sort of small GPU
uh okay
so so one question is like well this
seems really great why don't we just use
this for uh everything
um
uh-huh yeah uh and the answer is well
you know what is the sort of
pre-training objective what's the
structure of the pre-trained model good
for uh Bert is really good for sort of
filling in the blanks but it's much less
naturally used for actually generating
text right so I wouldn't want to use to
generate a summary of something because
it's not really built for it it's not it
doesn't have a natural notion of
predicting the next word given all the
words that came before it so maybe I
want to use Bert if I want a good
representation of say a document to
classify it give it one of a set of
topic labels or say it's toxic or
non-toxic or whatever but I wouldn't
want to use it to generate a whole
sequence
uh okay some extensions of Bert so we
had a question earlier of whether you
just mask things out randomly one thing
that seems to work better is uh you uh
mask out sort of whole contiguous spans
uh because uh sort of
the difficulty of this problem is much
easier than it would otherwise be
because uh sort of this is part of
irresistibly and you can tell very
easily based on the sort of sub words
that came before it whereas uh if I have
a much longer sequence it's a trade-off
but you know this might be a harder
problem and it ends up being better to
do this sort of span-based masking than
random masking and that might be because
sub words make very simple prediction
problems when you mask out just one sub
word of a word versus all the subwords
of a word
okay so those this ends up doing much
better there's also a paper called the
Roberta paper which showed that the next
sentence prediction wasn't neces wasn't
necessary they also showed that they
really should have trained it on a lot
more text so Roberta is a drop-in
replacement for Bert so if you're
thinking of using just use your Brita
it's better and it gave us this
intuition that we really don't know a
whole lot about the best practices for
training these things you sort of train
it for as long as you're willing to and
things do good stuff and whatever
um so this is very but it's very
difficult to do sort of uh iteration on
these models because they're big it's
expensive to train them
uh another thing that you should know
for your final projects in the world
ahead is this notion of fine-tuning all
parameters of the network versus just a
couple of them uh so what we've talked
about so far is you pre-train all the
parameters and then you fine-tune all of
them as well so all the parameter values
change uh an alternative which you call
parameter efficient or lightweight
fine-tuning uh you sort of choose little
bits of parameters or you choose the
very smart way of keeping most of the
parameters fixed and only fine-tuning
others and the intuition is that you
know these pre-trained parameters were
really good
and you want to make the minimal change
from the pre-trained model to the model
that does what you want so that you keep
some of the generality some of the
goodness of the pre-training
so one way that this is done is called
prefix tuning prompt tuning is very
similar where you actually freeze all
the parameters of the network so I've
pre-trained my network here
and I've never changed any of the
parameter values instead I make a bunch
of fake sort of pseudo word vectors that
I propend to the very beginning of the
sequence and I train just them sort of
unintuitive it's like these would have
been like inputs to the network but I'm
specifying them as parameters and I'm
training everything to do my sentiment
analysis task just by changing the
values of these sort of fake words
and this is nice because you know I get
to keep all the good pre-trained
parameters
um and then just specify this sort of
diff that ends up
generalizing better this is a very open
field of research but this is also
cheaper because I don't have to compute
the gradients or I don't have to store
the gradients and all the optimizer
state with respect to all these
parameters I'm only training a very
small number of parameters uh yeah
it's like make parameters and as if like
here but it doesn't make any difference
but he's at the end of the beginning in
a decoder you have to put them at the
beginning because otherwise you don't
see them before you process the whole
sequence
uh yes
a few layers I only train the new layers
but the question is can we just attach a
new layers of the sort of top of this
and only train those absolutely this
works a bit better
another thing that works well sorry
we're running out of time
um is taking each weight Matrix so I
have a bunch of weight matrices in my
Transformer and I freeze the weight
Matrix and learn a very low ranked
little diff and I set the weight
matrix's value to be sort of the
original Value Plus my my sort of very
low rank diff uh from the original one
and this ends up being a very similarly
useful technique and the overall idea
here is that again I'm learning way
fewer parameters than I did Via
pre-training and freezing most of the
pre-training parameters
okay encoder decoders so um for encoder
decoders we could do something like
language modeling right I've got my
input sequence here encoder output
sequence here and I could say this part
is my prefix for sort of having
bi-directional context and I could then
predict all the words that are sort of
in the latter half of the sequence just
like a language model and that would
work fine
um and so this this is something that
you could do right you sort of take it
along text split it into two give half
of it to the encoder and then generate
the second half with the decoder
uh but in practice what works much
better is this notion of span corruption
span corruption is going to show up in
your assignment five and the idea here
is a lot like Bert but uh in a sort of
generative sense where I'm going to mask
out a bunch of words in the input thank
you mask token one me to your party mask
token two week
and then at the output I generate the
mask token and then what was supposed to
be there but the mass token replaced it
right so thank you then predict for
inviting at the output meet your party
last week and what this does is that it
um allows you to have bi-directional
context right I get to see the whole
sequence except I can generate the parts
that we're missing
so this feels a little bit like you mask
out parts of the input but you actually
generate the output as a sequence like
you would in language modeling so this
might be good for something like machine
translation where I have an input that I
want bi-directional context in but then
I want to generate an output and I want
to pre-train the whole thing so this was
shown to work better than language
modeling at the scales that these uh
Folks at Google were able to test back
in 2018 this is still quite quite
popular
um yeah there's a lot of numbers it
works better than the other stuff
I'm not going to worry about it
um you know there's a fascinating
property of these models also so um so
T5 was the model that was originally uh
introduced with salience band masking
and you can think of you know at
pre-training time you saw a bunch of
things like Franklin D Roosevelt was
born in you know blank and you generated
out the blank and uh there's this task
called
um open domain question answering which
has a bunch of trivia questions like you
know when was Franklin D Roosevelt born
and then you're supposed to generate out
the answer as a string just like just
from your parameters right so you did a
bunch of pre-training you saw a bunch of
text and then you're supposed to
generate these answers and what's
fascinating is that this sort of
salience band masking method
allowed you to pre-train and then fine
tune on some examples of questions
trivia questions and then when you
tested on new trivia questions it would
sort of the model would sort of
implicitly extract from its pre-training
data somehow the answer to that new
question that it never saw explicitly at
fine tuning time so it learned this sort
of implicit retrieval sometimes
sometimes you know less than 50 of the
time or whatever but you know much more
than random chance yeah
um and that's just sort of fascinating
right so you've sort of learned to
access this sort of latent knowledge
that you stored up by pre-training and
so yeah you just pass it the text when
was Roosevelt born and it would pass out
an answer and one thing to know is that
the answers always look very fluent they
always look very reasonable but they're
frequently wrong and that's still true
of things like chat gbt
um
yeah
okay so that's that's like encoder
decoder models
um next up we've got decoders and we'll
spend a long time on decoders so this is
just our normal language model so I get
a sequence of hidden States for my
decoder the the models this words can
only look at themselves not the future
and then I predict you know the next
word in the sentence and then here again
I can you know to do sentiment analysis
maybe take the last state for the last
word and then predict happier sad based
on that last embedding back propagate
the gradients the whole network train
the whole thing or do some kind of
lightweight or or parameter efficient
fine tuning like we mentioned earlier so
this is our our you know pre-training a
decoder and um you know I can just
pre-train it on language modeling
um
so again you might want to do this if
you are wanting to generate
generate texts generate things uh this
is you sort of can use this like you use
an encoder decoder but in practice as
we'll see a lot of the sort of biggest
uh most powerful pre-trained models tend
to be decoder only it's not really clear
exactly why except they seem a little
bit simpler than encoder decoders
um and you get to share all the
parameters in one big Network for the
decoder whereas an encoder decoder you
have to split them sort of some into the
encoder some into the decoder so for the
rest of this lecture we'll talk only
about decoders so even and modern things
uh the biggest networks do tend to be
decoders
so we're coming all the way back again
to 2018 and the GPT model from openai
was a big success
it had 117 parameter a million
parameters uh it had you know 768
dimensional hidden States and uh it had
this vocabulary that was 40 000 ish
words that was defined via a method like
what we showed at the beginning of class
trained on Books Corpus and
um you know actually you know GPT never
actually showed up in the original paper
uh
the sort of uh it's unclear what exactly
it's supposed to refer to
um but uh this model was a precursor to
all the things that you're hearing about
nowadays uh if you move forward
uh oh yeah so if you
um
so if we wanted to do something like
natural language inference right which
says you know take these pairs of
sentences the man is in the doorway the
person is near the door and uh say that
these mean that one entails the other
the sort of premise entails the
hypothesis that I can believe the
hypothesis if I believe the premise I
just sort of concatenate them together
right so give it maybe a start token
pass in one sentence pass in some
delimiter token pass in the other and
then predict uh sort of yes no
entailment not entailment fine tuning
gbt on this it worked really well
um and then you know Bert came after GPT
Bert did a bit better it had
bi-directional context
um but you know it did it did uh sort of
an excellent job
and then came gpt2 where they focused
more on the generative abilities of the
network so
um right we looked at uh now a much
larger Network we've gone from 117
million to 1.5 billion and given some
sort of prompt it could generate at the
time a quite surprisingly coherent
continuation to The Prompt so it's
telling this sort of story about uh
about scientists and unicorns here
um and this size of model is still sort
of small enough that you can use on a
small GPU and fine-tune and whatever and
its capabilities of generating long
coherent texts was just sort of
um exceptional at the time
it was also trained on more data
although I don't
uh something like 9 billion words of
text
um and then so after gpt2 we come to
gpd3 sort of walking through these
models and then we come with a different
way of interacting with the models so
we've interacted with pre-trained models
in two ways so far we've sort of sampled
from the distribution that they Define
uh We've generated text via like a
machine translation system or whatever
or you fine-tuned them on a task that we
care about and then we take their
predictions
um but gpt3 seems to have an interesting
new ability uh it's much larger and it
can do some tasks without any sort of
fine-tuning whatsoever
uh gbd3 is much larger than gpd2 right
so we went from GPT 100-ish million
parameters gbd2 1.5 billion cpt3 175
billion much larger uh trained on 300
billion words of text and this sort of
notion of in context learning that it
could Define or figure out patterns in
the training or in the example that it's
currently seeing and continue the
pattern
uh is called in context learnings you
got you know the word thanks and I pass
in this little arrow and say okay thanks
goes to you know mercy and then hello
goes to bonjour and then you know they
give it all of these examples and ask it
um what you know otter should go to and
it's learned to sort of continue the
pattern and say that this is the
translation of otter so now remember
this is a single sort of input that I've
given to my to my model and I haven't
said oh do translation or fine tune it
on translation or whatever I've just
passed in the input given it some
examples and then it is able to to some
extent uh do this seemingly complex task
that's in context learning
uh and here are more examples you know
maybe you give it examples of addition
and then it can do some uh some simple
addition afterward uh you give it in
this case this is sort of rewriting
typos they can figure out how to rewrite
typos in context learning for for
machine translation and this was the
start of this idea that there were these
emergent properties that showed up in
much larger models and it wasn't clear
when looking at the smaller models that
you'd get this sort of new this
qualitatively new Behavior out of them
right like it's not obvious from just
the language modeling signal right gpt3
is just trained on that decoder only
just next predict the next word that it
would as a result of that training learn
to perform seemingly quite complex
things as a function of its context
um yeah okay one or two questions about
that
um this should be quite surprising I
think right like so far we've said
talked about good representations
contextual representations meanings of
words in context this is some very very
high level pattern matching right it's
coming up with patterns in just the
input data and that one sequence of text
that you've passed it so far and it's
able to sort of identify how to complete
the pattern uh and as you think what
kinds of things can this solve what are
its capabilities whether it's
limitations this ends up being an open
area of research sort of what are the
kinds of problems that you maybe saw in
the training data lab maybe gpt3 saw a
ton of pairs of words right they saw a
bunch of you know dictionaries bilingual
dictionaries in its training data so it
learned to do something like this or is
it doing something much more General
where it's really learning the task in
context you know the actual story we're
not totally sure something in the middle
it seems like it has to be tied to your
train data in ways that we don't quite
understand but there's also a
non-trivial ability to learn new sort of
at least types of patterns just from the
context so this is a very interesting
thing to work on
now we've talked a lot about the size of
these models so far and as models have
gotten larger they've always gotten
better we train them on more data
um right so gpd3 was trained on 300
billion words of text and it was 175
billion parameters
and you know at that scale it costs a
lot of money
to build these things and it's very
unclear whether you're getting the best
use out of your money like it's bigger
really what you should have been doing
in terms of the number of parameters
um so you know the cost of training one
of these is roughly you take the number
of parameters you multiply it by the
number of tokens that you're going to
train it on the number of words
and uh some folks at deepmind I forgot
the citation on this some folks at
deepmind uh realized through some
experimentation that actually gpt3 was
just comically oversized right so
chinchilla the model they trained is
less than half the size and works better
but they just trained it on way more
data
um and this is sort of an interesting
sort of trade-off about you know how do
you best spend your compute I mean you
can't do this more than a handful of
times even if you're you know Google
um so you know open open questions there
as well
um another sort of way of interacting
with these networks that has come out
recently is called Chain of Thought
um so the prefix right we saw in the in
context learning slide that the prefix
can help sort of specify what task
you're trying to solve right now and it
can do even more so here's standard sort
of prompting we have a prefix of
examples of questions and answers so you
have a question and then an example
answer so that's your prompt that's
specifying the task and then you have a
new question and you're having the model
generate an answer and it generates it
wrong
and Chain of Thought prompting uh says
well how about in the example in the
demonstration we give we give the
question and then we give this sort of
decomposition
of steps towards how to get an answer
right so I'm actually writing this out
as part of the input I'm I'm giving
annotations as a human to say oh you
know to solve this sort of word problem
here's how you could think it through
ish and then I give it a new question
and the model says oh I know what I'm
supposed to do I'm supposed to First
generate a sequence of steps
of intermediate steps and then next say
the answer is and then say what the
answer is and it turns out and this
should again be very surprising that the
model can tend to generate plausible
sequences of steps and then much more
frequently generates the correct answer
after doing so relative to trying to
generate the answer by itself
so you can think of this as a scratch
Pad you can think of this as uh
increasing the amount of computation
that you're putting into trying to solve
the problem
sort of writing out your thoughts right
as I generate each word of this
continuation here I'm able to condition
on all the past words so far and so
maybe it just uh
yeah allows the network to sort of
decompose the problem into smaller
simpler problems which is more able to
solve each
um
no one's really sure why this works
exactly either at this point with
networks that are this large they're
emergent properties are both very
powerful and exceptionally hard to
understand and very hard you should
think uh to trust
because it's unclear what its
capabilities are and what its
limitations are where it will fail
so what do we think pre-training is
teaching gosh a wide range of things
even beyond what I've written in this
slide which I mostly wrote two years ago
right so it can teach you trivia and
syntax and co-reference and maybe some
lexical semantics and sentiment and some
reasoning like way more reasoning than
we would have thought even three years
ago
um and yet they also learn and
exacerbate racism and sexism all manner
of biases
um there's more on this later but it's
uh the generality of this is really I
think what's taken many people aback and
so increasingly these objects are not
just
um studied for the sake of using them
but studied for the sake of
understanding anything about how they
work and how they fail
uh yeah any questions
has anyone tried like a benchmarking
like GPT for like programming tasks like
how accurate these does etc yeah the
question is has anyone tried
benchmarking GPT for programming tasks
anyone seen how well it does
um yes so there's definitely examples of
people using GPT uh three four simple
programming things and then you know the
modern state-of-the-art competitive
programming Bots are all based on ideas
from language modeling uh and I think I
think they're all also based on
pre-trained language models themselves
like if you just take all of these ideas
and apply it to like GitHub uh then you
get some very interesting emergent
behaviors relating to code uh fallout
and so yeah I think all of the best
systems use this more or less so lots of
benchmarking there for sure
through the basis for what like GitHub
co-pilot is going to do the question is
is this the basis is that what we just
mentioned the basis for the GitHub
copilot system yes absolutely
we don't know exactly what it is in
terms of details but it's all these
ideas
what if you have a situation where you
have you know still a large amount of
data for you know General data and then
you have also a large amount of data for
your fine tuning task at one point is it
better to train a new model for that
pioneering versus you know get data from
both yeah the question is what if you
have a large amount of data for
pre-training and a large amount of data
for fine tuning when is it better to do
sort of a separate training on just the
fine-tuning data
um almost never if you
have a bunch of data for the task that
you care about what's frequently done
instead is three-part training where you
pre-train on a very broad Corpus then
you sort of continue to pre-train using
something like language modeling on an
unlabeled version
of the label data that you have you just
like strip the labels off and just treat
it all as text and do language modeling
on that adapt the parameters a little
bit and then do the final stage of
fine-tuning with the labels that you
want and that works even better this
interesting paper called Don't Stop
pre-training
nice uh final question
that's a lot of questions on anyone new
new someone knew the question
yeah um I was wondering do you know if
there's like a lot of instances where a
pre-trained model can do some tasks not
soon before I even know
yeah so are there any instances of where
a pre-trained model can do a task that
it hasn't seen before uh you know
without fine-tuning the question is what
is hasn't seen before mean right like uh
these models especially gpt3 and similar
very large models you know during
pre-training did it ever see something
exactly like this sort of word problem
arithmetic maybe maybe not it's actually
sort of unclear it's clearly able to
recombine sort of bits and pieces of
tasks that it saw implicitly during
pre-training we saw the same thing with
trivia right like language modeling
looks a lot like trivia sometimes where
you just read the first paragraph of a
Wikipedia page and it's kind of like
answering a bunch of little trivia
questions about where someone was born
and when
um but like it's never seen something
quite like this and it's actually still
kind of astounding how much is able to
do things that don't seem like they
should have shown up all that directly
in the pre-training data quantifying
that extent is an open research problem
okay that's it let's call it foreign